hello you must be detective Hobbs I am
your new partner
Josh would say what you know I your last
partner Detective Jimenez I never met
him but I hear he he left some pretty
big shoes to fill
let's get one thing straight you're
never gonna fill him in as his shoes
ever
Minho's was a good man better cop Philly
Mena's his shoes the tip of your dick
couldn't fill a bottle cap I'm very
sorry if that came out wrong I'm sure in
Venice was a great cop the best okay so
these prostitute murders seems like a
serial killer could be I actually worked
out a theory I don't think you're a
hobos hat about your theory you think
your men has worked off of theories like
some kind of a needle-dick Charles
Darwin not on your ass
Mena's always shot straight from the
dick you think you're a menace
absolutely not you're goddamn right
you're not a menace would have busted 20
perps in the time it'd take you to pull
up your pants over your itsy-bitsy
teeny-weeny yellow polka-dot but peepee
two daughters raising them on his own
you want that job huh mr. baby dick what
is going on you want to be their daddy
no you know what I think I think we got
off on the wrong foot ninety minutes
jimenez got off on the right foot every
goddamn day of his goddamn life which is
more than i can say for your pebble
penis have an ass you Mendez wannabe I
can assure you I don't want to be a
minute why not what's wrong with a
minute there's nothing wrong with a
minute why wouldn't you want to be like
you said mother Becca okay time out I
can't I can't make this work man has
what I made it work come back from
Florida soon Jimenez
you